[Music]
education reformers love education
technology this has been true for a long
time the radio the TV the desktop
computers each was going to
revolutionize schooling guess what they
dinner technology is a powerful tool and
like any tool what matters is how we use
it you have to use it right and that
means understanding why it matter
technology is great at offering access
for kids in rural schools you don't have
access to advanced placement classes
online delivery of courses to make all
the difference technology is great at
supporting personalization for teachers
with 25 kids it can be hard to tend to
the needs of each and every one
computerized assessment can make a huge
difference but iPads aren't going to
eliminate the need for teachers kids
need role models mentors and a kick in
the pants technology can't do any of
that but technology can make a huge
difference it can help teachers do their
job better and it can support kids as
they learn and honestly that's more than
enough to learn more about my take on
education technology check the links in
the description below also let us know
what other topics you'd like ati
scholars to cover in 60 seconds